we've been talking to the always
inspirational ava duvernay about her new
amazing series on the cw
naomi and it's about a teenage girl who
discovers that she is a superhero and
played by 17 year old casey walthall
who's also here with us today hi casey
hi how are you
i'm so excited about this project but
this is your first leading tv role and
you were on broadway in the lion king
playing nala which is so incredibly
impressive
thank you
and now you're getting to work with one
of your own personal heroes ava duvernay
and will you talk about
that coolest fact ever
it is the coolest fact ever just keeping
miss ava in my contact in my phone is so
cool
uh when i first met her it was a feeling
of nurturing that she's kept within our
relationship she's always a call away
she's always a text away and when you're
in miss ava's environment you just want
to be the best version of yourself
because she always is and seeing her
interact with everyone on set is truly
inspiring
now ava you um are you a superhero geek
is there something particular about this
story that really spoke to you what was
the theme in it that made you know you
had to do this
yeah i mean i love i love the idea of
these these stories these epic majestic
stories that kind of embed the idea that
anyone can be a hero or that there's
some kind of heroism inside of all of us
so i've always been really attracted to
superhero comics for that reason but
when naomi
this great comic by brian bendis and
david f walker came across my desk
i fell in love with the image of this
black teenager who is a superman stan
she is a fan of comic books she is a
comic book character but she's a fan of
comic books in the story she loves
superman so much and through her love of
superman she starts to understand why
she's so attracted to the idea of
superman because she's like him in more
ways than she knows and so that's kind
of what the premise of the story is and
to do that you have to find a very
special actor uh to play that and so i'm
so blessed that we crossed paths with
casey and yet
when you called her
to talk about if the role was going to
happen or not
did you do it in a straightforward
manner or was there something to it
i don't know casey how was it
my mom walked into my room and said
someone wants to talk to you so i
answered the phone it was ava and she
said
casey i want to thank you so much for
coming in and auditioning and it almost
sounded like she wasn't going to give me
the role
and then she said i would love to invite
you to the right family to play naomi oh
i love it tension builder
i was a good actress i was a good
actress gracie
really i i believed you i believed you
thank you thank you there's something
very fun about that so i i liked that
story now before you guys go i was
wondering would you play a round of the
final six with me
[Applause]
it's the final pick
okay ava what's your latest food craving
my latest sunflower seeds
casey what song is going to represent
2022 for you
everything is everything by lauren hill
yeah
great
yes
ava if you could remake any movie would
there be one
you know what i love i love dirty
dancing oh
yeah
that might be fun it's a great movie and
if you were to cast baby like does
anyone spark to mind
yes casey waffle
oh
all right start practicing casey
okay casey can you tell us an instagram
account that we need to follow
um
i would probably say
refinery29 they have really nice things
up there really inspirational things and
fun things too ava what would you want
your super power to be if you could have
one
oh that's fun to think about
i've always say invisibility okay casey
describe ava in one word she's so she's
a lot more she's a lot than one word but
if i were to say one word but for miss
ava
i would just say
nurturing
it's really nurturing and she's a
powerhouse but she's so kind to be
around i knew it
i could sense it thank you my favorite
do renee casey waffle you can watch
naomi tuesdays on the cw
[Music]